good morning Hank it's question Tuesday
the day that I answer real questions
from real nerdfighters okay I wasn't me
it was Paul de George of Harry and the
Potters that's right Hank half of Harry
and the Potters were in my house
by the way nerdfighters if you don't
know who Harry and the Potters are your
life is about to get a lot better link
in the sidebar okay hang time to answer
some questions how's the vlogbrothers
2009 fitness challenge going I've lost
like three pounds but I'm pretty sure
that Hank is going to win the BMI part
of the challenge which means I have to
focus on running and push-ups and any
time that I have to rely on push-ups I'm
in a bit of a pickle or any of your
books available in Spanish
yes buscando alaska behind your head is
that a polar bear with a top hat do you
mean the My Little Pony with a hand
painted black Santa on at the bottom or
do you mean the wooden shoes I got from
the ladies of best wishes from NL oh no
I think you mean the sculpture of the
dread pirate fireball Wilson Roberts
Willy kiss your likeness yes it well you
asked my girlfriend to marry me what
well I what seriously I mean Hank I know
that sometimes nerdfighters meet other
nerdfighters and they fall a nerdfighter
like and I know that occasionally that
nerdfighter like leads to nerdfighter
love but I don't know if I'm prepared to
propose to someone other than my wife
in fact tank as you may remember I
didn't even ask the Yeti to marry me I
made hendrik hertzberg do it when he
signed my copy of his book politics okay
oh boy Hank I can't do this until I
shave and dress up all right I'm back
whoo I'll tell you what Hank I'm a lot
more nervous than I was when I asked
that girl to prom okay it's dialing hi
is this Kelly yeah hi this is Jon green
of the vlogbrothers how are you
your boyfriend Phil you know him he
contacted me and he told me that I
signed your book with the wrong name but
I spelled your name wrong I'm calling to
apologize
it's still there with you by the way I
have another small question for you
actually yeah
will you marry him yeah yes she said yes
she said yes da huzzah ah I'm shaking
heck I'm so excited I'm shaking yeah
Kelly and Phil congratulations thanks
for being made of Awesome thanks for
being part of our community and best
wishes yes Hank I'll see you tomorrow